>>Sal Khan: People have been integrating
technology in the classroom forever.
What I think is really exciting
about what we're seeing now is
that technology is being used
to fundamentally transform
what the classroom is.
Fundamentally transform what
you can do with a classroom.
>>Adam Bellow: I think to define
technology integration,
it's really using whatever
resources you have
to the best of your abilities.
Technology, it's a tool.
It's what you do with that
tool, what you can make,
what you allow the students to make.
That's really what
technology is about.
If you can do this lesson
without technology, that's great.
But if you can do it
better with technology,
then that's why you use it.
That's why you use tools.
>>Divya: This is a list of different
applications that you can use
to like make music or do art.
I've used it to record some
of my personal narratives
that I've wroten [sic].
>>Divya: My eyes were drooping.
I was drifting off to sleep.
>>Mary Beth Hertz: Students today are
creating using digital tools.
They're not creating
using analog tools.
For us to feel like we really
are connecting with our kids,
and to make learning fun
for our kids and meaningful,
we need to meet them where they are.
>>Mary Beth: Kids can
create podcasts, movies,
songs to express their ideas,
express their thoughts.
but also to express their learning.
>>Adam: When you create, you
take ownership of your learning.
You understand it in
a very different way
than if you just memorize
something from a textbook,
or if you just read it
over and over again,
or watched it in someone else's film.
If you were able to translate that
information into your own film,
your own content, your
own something to share.
That's just amazing.
>>Mary Beth: And sometimes they
learn things we didn't expect them
to learn.
Like I had my second graders
reflect on the project they did,
and some of them said, "I learned
how to get along with somebody," or,
"I learned how to work
with somebody."
>>Mary Beth: This internet thing that
has become a big part of our lives.
It's really enabled people
around the world to connect
in ways we never imagined.
>>Adam: People always say
that the kids respond better
when they're able to
share their work.
Well, of course!
Because they have a valid audience.
It doesn't go into a pile
on the teacher's desk,
and then get handed
back to their folder.
Kids today can create stuff and
share it with the entire world.
And they have that
authentic audience.
They have people that actually,
not only will read it,
but also care about it.
>>Mia: We have to make
like a movie project.
So you kind of have--
you have a topic.
And with your topic, you
speak into a microphone,
and then you draw pictures to
go with what you're saying.
>>Asim: If they have the link to
our website, which they might end
up getting-- like searching something
on Google, and this might pop up.
And so yeah, there
is a chance of kids
around the world getting
to see these videos.
>>Sal: The traditional academic
model, you know, that we've inherited
from the Prussians 200 years ago
is: We have a set amount of time
to learn something, and
then there's an exam.
You get a B; I get a C. Even
though the exam identified
that you have some basic weaknesses,
I have even more weaknesses,
we'll then move on
to the next concept.
So instead of doing that
traditional, everyone move together
in lock-step model, with
technology, you have the potential
to everyone learn at their own pace,
and master concepts
before they move on.
Have the teacher get
real-time dashboards
to see who's stuck on what.
Now something like that is
a fundamental transformation
of what a classroom is.
>>Adam: The role of the
teacher has shifted.
I'm truly seeing a world where
the person who's in the role
of teacher is really a facilitator.
And if you can facilitate your
students to create great work,
and work alongside with them to
do that, that's amazing to me.
>>Mary Beth: It's not about the mode
of creation, it's not about the tool,
it's about the learning, it's about
the process, it's about the look
on my students' faces, the fact that
they can stay focused, motivated,
engaged, and they're sharing ideas.
It really makes learning joyful.